[Music]
straight ahead on lawn crime daily
closing arguments in the derrick chauvin
trial as the jury deliberates the fate
of the former minneapolis officer
charged in the death of george floyd
this wasn't policing
this was murder the defense firing back
reminding the jury chauvin is presumed
innocent
this was an authorized use of force as
unattractive
as it may be our team coverage as
protesters take to the streets
as we await a verdict plus the former
home of a witness for the defense
vandalized law and crime daily covering
court cases from coast to coast
[Music]
and welcome to long crime daily
everybody i'm jesse weber in
our studios along with brian buckmeyer
who's in minneapolis covering the
derrick chauvin trial
and with us as always his co-host terry
austin closing arguments in the trial of
the former officer charged in the death
of george floyd
prosecutors got to go first and brian
buckmeyer is here to explain the state's
version of events brian
yeah jesse the prosecution began began
their closing arguments with an
impassioned argument
about who george floyd was and kind of
painting
the picture for the jury now prosecutor
steve slasher married the charges
with the facts of the case leading the
jury down the path to a conviction
showing what facts no matter how small
or how large they are
could fit into the definition of all
three of the charges
steve slescher also took the time to
point out the arguments
that the defense was likely to make and
let the jury know
why they were not something that they
should be focusing on prosecutor steve
slasher told the jury that george floyd
was not a threat that day
nine minutes and 29 seconds nine minutes
and 29 seconds
during this time george floyd struggled
desperate to breathe but the force was
too much
he was he was trapped he was trapped
with the unyielding pavement underneath
him
as unyielding as the men who held him
down
a knee to the neck a knee to the back
twisting his fingers holding his legs
for nine minutes
and 29 seconds the defendant's weight on
him
as he desperately pushed with his
knuckles
to make space so he'd have room to
breathe the pavement
lacerating lacerating his knuckles
the defendant stayed on top of him for
nine minutes
and 29 seconds so desperate to breathe
he pushed with his face with his face
a grown man crying out for his mother
a human being prosecutors then reminded
the jury of the testimony of their
medical experts who say
floyd died due to the knee on his neck
the experts have weighed in and you know
dr
langenfield told you that mr floyd died
dr baker ruled this a homicide
and told you the cause and manner of
death the unlawful
the restraint and subduel by law
enforcement
what they did killed him told you that
dr tobin you remember dr tobin
he told you specifically how it happened
he walked you through that the asphyxia
he told you how it happened and the
other
doctors who testified dr smock dr rich
dr eisenschmidt they told you how it
didn't happen
like it wasn't a sudden cardiac event it
wasn't a heart attack
wasn't a drug overdose it wasn't any of
those things
right dr tobin came back and explained
it wasn't carbon monoxide
and was very clear that george floyd
died as a result of a low level of
oxygen
this low level of oxygen caused a brain
injury
and a pea arrhythmia which caused his
heart to stop that's not a cardiac event
it's not that
his heart disease right that didn't
cause him to die
it was the low level of oxygen it was
the asphyxia that caused him to die
defense attorney eric nelson told the
jury that derek chovin is presumed
innocent
and that the state failed to prove their
case beyond a reasonable doubt
capricious fanciful
capricious stout capricious means
unpredictable
fanciful space aliens flew in
inhabited the body of derek chauvin
and caused this death that's fancy
beyond the reasonable doubt
it is the highest standard in the law
doesn't mean beyond all possibility of
doubt because i suppose
space aliens may have been inhabiting
his body but that's obviously fanciful
and capricious
now the defense also talked about that
late testimony concerning george floyd's
carbon monoxide levels addressing the
state's rebuttal witness who said floyd
had 98 oxygen in his blood when he died
you can't come in and say george floyd
on one hand
george floyd died of asphyxiation but he
has a 98
oxygen level right his blood is
oxygenated
then it is stands for reason the
opposite is true
as well you can't come in and say
i can conclusively prove that mr floyd
have carbon monoxide in his blood
because he had this high oxygen
saturation
compare the evidence against itself
test it challenge it compare it to the
law
read the instructions in their entirety
start from the point of the presumption
of innocence
and see how far the state can get
i submit to you that the state has
failed
to meet its burden of proof beyond a
reasonable doubt
okay let's break it down terry you heard
all the evidence in the case do you
think that the prosecution was able to
tie it all together for the jury
i think slasher did an excellent job
tying it together he
started out humanizing george floyd he
specifically talked about where he was
born when he was born
his mother etc and then he said what the
last
words were coming from his mouth they
were words of respect he said
mr officer please i can't breathe so i
definitely thought he started out well
then he went into each of the counts and
he talked about the elements of the
counts
and the other tactic that he did during
this closing which i thought was
extremely effective
instead of going witness by witness he
talked about the issues and he
specifically
named the witnesses so in the clip we
saw there where he was talking about the
medical evidence
he named the doctors and he specifically
said this one told you how he died and
this one told you how he didn't die
right so i thought that was effective as
well
and brian what did you make of the
defense's argument did they create
reasonable doubt
i think the defense was able to sow some
kind of reasonable doubt here or there
the issue that i had with their
arguments that they were making
is that they kind of left the answer in
the air there's this hypothetical that
eric nelson used
about the reasonable officer leaving
someone in a hot car and then dying on
their own of a heart attack
yeah great example but derek shovin's
actions sound more like the individual
who left someone in a hot car
than someone who just simply died of a
heart attack eric nelson kept
bringing us to a point of reasonable
doubt in talking about a reasonable
officer a reasonable officer
at this point i don't know if he's
representing derek chovin or a
reasonable officer
because he's not making the connection
between the two all right well
still ahead on law and crime daily
protesters take to the streets to
remember
george floyd but first how the jury's
instructions could play an important
role in deliberations
our exclusive illegal analysis up next
[Music]
welcome back everybody before jurors and
derek shovin's trial heard
closing arguments the judge read
instructions to them about the law
long crimes angenette levy's here live
in minneapolis with what the joe
the judge told the jurors angenette
yeah jesse jury instructions really lay
out for the jurors what they are to
consider when evaluating the three
charges in this case
and they are very tedious and at times
confusing
the defendant does not have to prove his
innocence judge peter cahill drafted the
jury instructions with input from the
prosecution
and the defense the instructions are a
road map for the jurors
the fact that other causes contribute to
the to the death does not relieve the
defendant of criminal liability
the medical examiner testified that
george floyd's death was a homicide
caused by being restrained by police but
that floyd had heart disease and
fentanyl and methamphetamine in his
system
under the jury instructions chauvin
could still be guilty despite those
facts
chauvin faces three charges second
degree murder is the most serious
it's an unintentional murder that
happened as a result of a third degree
assault
intent is an element of the assault it
is not necessary that the defendant have
this
intent in advance the necessary intent
can develop
during the commission of the act chauvin
also faces a third degree murder charge
which includes acting with reckless
disregard for life
and conscious indifference a person
causing the death of another
by perpetrating an act eminently
dangerous to others
and evincing a depraved mind without
regard for human life
but without intent to cause the death of
any person second-degree manslaughter is
the lowest level charge
meaning the death was the result of
negligence and the person accused took
actions that had the chance of causing
the death
law and crime legal analyst gene rossi
discusses the importance of the
instructions
whatever those instructions are you want
it very
narrow so that when the prosecution
tries to make their closing in rebuttal
they have a very uh thin lane
and and you don't want them to have any
broad brush uh
arguments that they can make
now the jury instructions also include
language about being aided
and abetted by others in the commission
of these crimes
that was added since there were three
other officers involved in this incident
jesse terry if the judge explains the
law then why does the prosecution
explain it again to the jury
question and i'm sure the jury is
thinking the same thing the reason is
because the prosecution has to tie in
the law
to the facts so for instance this second
degree unintentional murder while
committing an assault
the judge defined what an assault is he
said there is bodily injury
what steve schlesher did was he
explained bodily injury
includes for instance loss of
consciousness and he actually showed
a picture of george floyd when he was
losing consciousness
and when he had the scrapes so he made
that connection between
the assault and what actually happened
and i think he did a great job
now angenettes my understanding that the
judge included an instruction to the
jury about george floyd's
drug use am i right yeah that's correct
jesse and
he discussed that this morning in the
morning during the morning session of
the opening statements before
the opening statements even began and he
said that the drug use
they are not to consider that when
assessing george floyd's character that
is not what this
is about and why it was presented in
court this is about looking at
the condition of george floyd during the
arrest before the arrest
and about what may have caused his death
in the jury's mind so that is why
there's to look at the drug use in this
case
look jury instructions so important they
are a guide map a
road map for this jury the question of
course is
do they actually follow it in the
deliberations that's something we will
not know but you hopefully
think that they will at the end of the
day the jury are human beings and it's
difficult to know what is guiding them
all right coming up on long crime daily
a deeper dive into closing arguments by
the state and defense in the derrick
chauvin trial
plus the former house of a defense
defense witness
targeted the message vandals left after
the break
[Music]
as the derrick chauvin trial winds down
inside the courtroom
people have been demonstrating outside
in the streets
long crimes kim johnson is in
minneapolis and has the latest kim
hi jesse as the end of the derek chovin
trial draws
closer tensions continue to build and
grow
in and around minneapolis thousands of
uniformed and armed national guard men
and
women have been patrolling streets and
neighborhoods and
in numbers that i've never seen before
not even close
this has always been part of the plan
though as we approach the verdict but
law enforcement and the guard have
really ramped up their public presence
after last week's deadly shooting of an
unarmed black man by a police officer
during a traffic stop in the town just
right next over
now protests have gone on eight
nights now after the shooting sometimes
turning violent with protesters hurling
objects at police that has resulted in
police using tear gas and rubber bullets
to disperse crowds
still lingering after nightly curfews
the chief of the minnesota state patrol
knows more protests are possible after a
verdict in the chauvin trial
and has this message for those wanting
to demonstrate their first amendment
rights
we want people to leave like we don't
want to arrest people
and i think that can sometimes be
confused like the goal of law
enforcement is not
every night to see how many people we
can arrest as part of operation safety
net
our goal is to plead and ask and direct
and
and help people understand how not to
get arrested by
by listening to our simple advice now
also over the weekend
vandalism in other parts of the country
in light of what's happening in
minnesota vandals
threw a pig's head at the one time
home of a former california police
officer
who was a defense witness in the chauvin
trial the house where
barry broad used to live was smeared
with pig's blood police say he was
falsely targeted over his testimony
that chauvin's use of force was
justified
but here in minneapolis storefronts
continue to be boarded up
by the hour city schools are preparing
to close
completely this week out of safety
precautions and the law enforcement and
military presence
is so thick here in minneapolis i had
one person tell me they feel like
they are in a movie it just seems
surreal of what's happening
i can tell you though it's really only a
matter of time between before the
streets
of surrounding the courthouse are going
to be filled with
demonstrators as we know that there are
rallies being planned
as we speak as we approach verdict time
jesse
wow it's pretty incredible kim just to
clarify what are the protesters calling
for when it comes to the verdict
well i have been covering this trial
since day one and been
really in tuned with protesters in the
community and what they've been asking
for really since
george floyd died on may 25th 2020
and mostly they want derek shovin found
guilty on
all three charges not just one not just
two but they won a guilty verdict
on all three on the second degree murder
the third degree murder and the
secondary manslaughter
as well they have said on facebook that
they plan
widespread protests take to the streets
if they don't get
a guilty verdict on all three charges
pretty incredible kim johnson thank you
so much when we come back
more from closing arguments in the
derrick chauvin trial
which side will the jury believe up next
[Music]
back now to our coverage of closing
arguments in the derrick chauvin trial
prosecutors say the former officer is
guilty of all three charges against him
how can you justify the continued force
on this man when he has no pulse
no pulse the restraint continued
grinding and twisting and pushing him
down and crushing the very life
out of him it wasn't too late he could
have rolled him over performed cpr
no he continued past the point of
finding a pulse
past the point where the ambulance
arrives past the point where the emts
get out
this was a counterfeit 20 bill allegedly
right what is going on why
why hold him that long past that point
past that line that was crossed oh
unreasonable force not proportional
excessive it violated
policy it violated the law it violated
everything
that the minneapolis police department
stood for
it was not lawful defense attorney eric
nelson though told the jury that
chauvin's use of force was justified and
that he was simply following police
policy
simply because someone isn't stabbing
you
or punching you or shooting at you
it doesn't mean that you can't use force
and that is specifically in the
minneapolis police department policy
on the non-deadly use of force that
we've looked at a couple of times
the use of force is an incredibly
difficult
analysis you can't limit it to 9 minutes
and 29 seconds it started
17 minutes before that nine minutes and
29 seconds
in this case the totality of the
circumstances that
were known to a reasonable police
officer
in the precise moment the force
was used demonstrates that this was
an authorized use of force
as unattractive as it may be
and this is reasonable doubt
okay let's get some perspective brian
what sort of reaction
are you seeing if any from the jury
during closing arguments
so from what we're getting from the pull
report notes the jury is really paying
attention to those definitions when
they see a lot of the graphics that are
used by both sides the defense and the
prosecution
giving the definition of use of force
giving the definition
uh or the the charts that we're seeing
of various incidents we're really seeing
them taking notes on that
not so much on just kind of the more
ad-lib arguments or just kind of the
reactions from the prosecution of the
defense so it's interesting to see what
they're focusing on and what they're not
so much based on the writing of notes
terry let's focus on the defense for a
second eric nelson spent a
great deal of time setting the scene and
trying to get the jury to see the
totality of the circumstances
was that right or was it a little
excessive for the jury was it too much
i think it was way too much he went on
way too long
look he talked about legal issues that i
think the jury already knows about the
presumption of innocence beyond a
reasonable doubt
he talked about this perspective versus
perception
when he finally began to talk about the
actual
facts here he discussed what happened on
the scene
from 802 when the call first came in to
his death 8 25 that critical moment
and basically he talked too long
about what happened beforehand because
no one really is putting in dispute the
fact that
the force was reasonable beforehand so i
think that uh
it was not relevant and i think he spent
way too long and i think the jury wasn't
happy
all right well we'll wait and see what
the jury thinks uh terry brian thank you
so much and everyone out there thanks
for joining us here
on long crime daily we'll see you next
time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
you